[Musique]
lorsque j'étais enfant j'aimais démonter
les choses pour comprendre comment elles
fonctionnent à l'intérieur jamais les
ouvrir en voir les rouages les
mécanismes je démontais tous mes parents
étaient ravis et rarement je les
remonter cette curiosité ses désirs cet
appétit ne m'a jamais quitté aujourd'hui
je ne demande plus tellement d'objets
même si ça m'arrive encore je ne
construis pas non plus de choses je ne
suis pas mécanicienne je ne répare pas
je n'ouvre pas non plus les gens pour
savoir comment ils fonctionnent à
l'intérieur je ne suis pas chirurgienne
je m'intéresse aux systèmes aux
organisations au processus
je m'intéresse à la façon dont les
systèmes qui font fonctionner les choses
fonctionnent et plus spécifiquement dans
l'ère numérique dans laquelle nous
vivons je m'intéresse aux systèmes
technologiques
je m'intéresse aux algorithmes et je
m'intéresse à la façon dont les
personnes travaillent sur les
algorithmes je regarde comment ces
personnes travaillent c'est très
agréable de regarder les gens travailler
je m'intéresse à la façon dont ils
conçoivent des choses dont ils
parviennent à des résultats
et comment ils collaborent entre eux je
ne fais pas que les observer je les aide
aussi et je travaille aujourd'hui a
construit des algorithmes au service de
l'intérêt général alors un algorithme
qu'est ce que c'est un algorithme comme
chacun sait c'est une procédure
mathématiques formelle qui réalise un
résultat dont un nombre fini d'étape
vous saviez tout ça bien sûr un
algorithme c'est une recette de cuisine
on va prendre des ingrédients on va
prendre des instructions et à la fin on
aura un bon boeuf bourguignon où quelque
chose de moins ragoûtants et si j'ai
envie de vous parler aujourd'hui c'est
parce que du côté des algorithmes on se
retrouve avec des choses qui n'ont pas
forcément un fumée fameux j'aimerais
vous parler sans vous alarmer de ses
algorithmes qui nous entourent et qui
sont derrière beaucoup de choses qui
sont aujourd'hui dans notre société
j'aimerais vous parler des algorithmes
qui alimente nos réseaux sociaux
au kino proches qui nous proposait nous
projette des flux infinie d'information
et entretiennent nos addictions
j'aimerais vous parler des algorithmes
qui sont derrière les assistants vocaux
les objets auxquels on parle et qui ont
quelques difficultés à nous comprendre
lorsqu'on a un accent chantant du sud de
la france
un accent un peu plus épais de la région
de liège un défaut de prononciation
j'aimerais vous parler de ces
algorithmes qui vont déterminer nos
choix et notre futur
ceux qui en france l'année dernière ont
conduit deux jeunes bacheliers à un
avenir incertain puisque ces algorithmes
ont déterminé dans quelle formation dans
quelle école ils allaient pouvoir aller
les algorithmes de recrutement qui vont
suggérer à des recrues taire certains
candidats ou candidates mais plus
souvent des candidats au détriment de
certaines autres des algorithmes en fois
qu ils nous discriminent sur des
questions lourdes celle du genre mais
aussi celle de l'origine ethnique et qu'
il y a quelques années les algorithmes
de reconnaissance vocale qui n'arrivait
pas à reconnaître des personnes des
personnes qui n'étaient pas blanche
parce que ses algorithmes avaient été
entraînés sur des personnes qui
ressemblait à leurs concepteurs et
n'avait pas inclus finalement la
majorité de la population
donc si j'ai envie de vous parler de ces
sujets aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il me
semble que la situation est plutôt
alarmante mais pas sans espoir pour
comprendre cela on peut se demander
finalement mais comment est-ce qu'on en
est arrivé là qu'est ce qui se passe
dans la tête des gens qui se disent on
va faire comme ça comment est-ce qu'on a
merdé
imaginons que vous êtes directeur des
ressources humaines dans une grande
banque
quelqu'un d'important quelqu'un de
sérieux et vous lisez dans la presse que
paraît-il le recrutement serait un peu
discriminant entre les personnes qui ne
sont pas des hommes blancs qui ont fait
une grande école
et si possible qui ont un nom à
particule vous vous dites pourquoi pas
je vais recruter des personnes
spécialiste des algorithmes des
informaticiens des datations tease
vouloir soumettre le problème
et puis ils vont faire un algorithme qui
va résoudre ce problème là qui va me
débarrasser de mes biais de mes
pratiques de mai discrimination de la
façon dont moi je profite ce le jeu
procède
après tout c'est mathématique donc ses
objectifs
ce sera pas biaisé et en face de ça on a
effectivement déjà des datations tease
des informaticiens des ingénieurs qui
vont dire quel merveilleux problème on
va d biaiser la société on va faire en
sorte que le recrutement soit plus juste
plus équitable moins discriminant et
malheureusement c'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'il se passe et dans cette situation
là ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est
finalement rejeté la faute sur la
galerie ce qu'on a voulu faire c'est ben
finalement investiguer ouvrir
l'algorithme pour comprendre comment ils
fonctionnent et moi au départ ça aurait
pu me plaire mais ce tour se rencontrent
c'est que finalement où le problème
n'est pas vraiment là il ya eu beaucoup
d'initiatives ces dernières années pour
justement ouvrir le code des algorithmes
pour voir comment il fonctionne je ne
sais pas si vous avez déjà vu le code
d'un algorithme moi oui c'est un peu
pour sujet et je peux vous dire qu'en
général je ne comprends rien je ne
comprends rien et je ne vois pas
vraiment où est le problème
donc je pense que si effectivement en
tant que société on se donne la
possibilité de voir le code des
algorithmes ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
les rendra plus juste et c'est
d'ailleurs aussi ce que font les
personnes qui conçoivent et développent
des algorithmes ils ne se disent pas
forcément entre eux on n'a pas forcément
besoin de traiter les algorithmes
autrement que comme des boîtes noires
ont fait confiance à la personne qui
s'occupe de cet aspect là et nous on
s'occupe d'un autre aspect est quelqu'un
on coordonne tout ça et à la fin on a un
système qui est complet c'est
aujourd'hui comme ça que l'industrie du
logiciel fonctionne ce qu'on fait aussi
s'est testé les algorithmes non pas sur
leurs codes sur leur fonctionnement mais
sur les résultats qu'ils produisent on
va se dire est ce que ce résultat est
bon est ce que ce résultat est mauvais
comment est ce que je peut l'améliorer
et là effectivement on va retravailler
le code
le problème en fait ce sont les données
si je prends si je reprends par exemple
mon histoire de d'algorithmes de
recrutement comment est ce qu'on fait un
outil comme celui là et bien on va aller
chercher l'historique des données dont
on peut disposer
on va aller chercher des cv on va aller
chercher des échanges de mails entre des
candidats et des candidates mais souvent
des candidats et des recruteurs et aussi
des recruteuses mais surtout des
recruteurs cd milieu un peu sexiste 1 on
va aller chercher ces informations là on
va les analyser
et puis l'algorithme il va prendre
toutes ces informations les agréger les
synthétiser et il va fournir à la fin
des propositions qui seront
merveilleusement parfaitement similaires
aux discriminations qu'on a fait jusqu'à
maintenant parce que il n'aura fait que
reproduire ce qu'il avait dans les
données il n'aura fait que reproduire
les comportements qu'on a pu observer
précédemment donc le problème il est
dans les données
il est dans le choix des données qu'on
va utiliser il est dans notre capacité à
questionner ces données à les interroger
allez choisir à les transformer à les
filtrer à les redresser
il est dans notre capacité à les
comprendre
ah les contextualiser allez trouver
aussi parce que le problème c'est que
elle n'existe pas toujours
et on n'a pas forcément des informations
qui sont pertinentes pensez toujours à
votre cv est ce que vous pensez que
votre date de naissance votre adresse
ton pertinent pour savoir si vous êtes
un bon candidat une bonne candidate
penser à tout ce que vous avez mis
dessus
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est sur ces
informations là que vous avez envie
d'être évalués suis pas certaine la
première chose donc c'est de
s'intéresser aux données et la deuxième
chose ça va être de s'intéresser aux
concepteurs aux conceptrice aux
designers aux ingénieurs aux
spécialistes des données et à la façon
dont ils travaillent une chose qu'on
peut faire aussi c'est changer la façon
dont on travaille parce que finalement
dans cette histoire on avait notre
commanditaire monsieur très sérieux
directeur d'une grande banque qui va
faire une commande à des spécialistes
plutôt technique et finalement dans tout
ça on n'a vu aucun en expert en
recrutement
on n'a vu aucun candidate aucune
candidate aucun candidat
on n'a pas vu finalement les gens qui
sont pertinents pour traiter ce genre de
questions et ça ça pose quand même un
peu question est donc si je devais
finalement résoudre ce problème là je
crois que j'aurais plusieurs
propositions qui sont en rapport avec le
fait que les personnes qui conçoivent
des algorithmes aujourd'hui un pouvoir
incroyable et que donc la façon dont on
peut résoudre ce problème c'est de façon
politique première dimension politique
ça va être peut-être de tenter de
réguler et de réglementer cette
profession si on pense à d'autres
professions qui ont du pouvoir de la
responsabilité
on voit que c'est des professions qui se
sont posé ce genre de questions un
médecin appartient à un ordre des
médecins
il peut être radié de l'ordre des
médecins est interdit de pratiquer en
avocat pareil un ingénieur en génie
civil prête serment et s'engage un vrai
pour le bien commun
pourquoi est ce que les ingénieurs en
informatique
les spécialistes des données n'ont pas
d'engagement de ce type là alors qu'ils
ont un impact énorme aujourd'hui sur la
société dans laquelle nous vivons un
deuxième aspect c'est de répartir ce
pouvoir c'est de donner à d'autres
personnes la capacité à faire des choix
et à prendre des décisions dans ces
outils qui détermine nos vies c'est donc
permettre aux futures candidates aux
futurs candidats à des recruteurs des
recruteuses toujours pour se reprendre
cet exemple de donner leur avis de
comprendre comment les choses
fonctionnent d'interroger ce qui se dit
d'avoir un droit de réponse et nous
mêmes en fait citoyen toi public tu
devrais pouvoir répondre comprendre et
reprendre le pouvoir sur ces objets là
et enfin
la dern cette dernière façon d'utiliser
ce pouvoir est vain c'est de le
renverser
c'est de se révolter c'est d'avoir ce
sursaut moral en tant que concepteur
en tant que designer en tant
qu'ingénieur en tant que spécialiste des
zones est et de se dire ce problème
n'est pas un bon problème
cette question n'est pas une bonne
question et avec le pouvoir qui m'est
donnée avec la place qui m'est accordée
je refuse de résoudre ce problème je
désobéis et l'oeuvre ainsi à rendre une
société d'un meilleur qu'elle n'est
aujourd'hui
merci
[Musique]